you already mentioned that these new
these media organizations tend to drift
left
well
there's there's both fox definitely it
has gone way right
right tucker carlson has become
increasingly more populist and
supportive of previous left-wing
positions now hannity i'm not a big fan
of but hold on hold on there a minute
mike.com is a really great example and
uh uh i'll tell you why i think this is
happening and probably why it is
happening mike.com when they first
started they were libertarian they were
pro ron paul right but within a few
years they became completely woke why
at facebook and twitter and youtube what
is deemed safe
wokeness so i had this conversation with
jack dorsey for for instance there are
certain things you can't say on social
media it almost always favors the left
but you're massively successful and i'm
doing the opposite of that and i'm a
centrist i mean come on like like there
are there are certainly right-wing like
joe rogan joe rogan's not right-wing
well no i wouldn't say he i wouldn't i
wouldn't say this either but well then
maybe like the right has been decimated
on social media and so these companies
see the algorithm certainly the left
would say the other thing but
when when when mike.com starts off
libertarian and then becomes woke when
vice dot com starts off as an edgy bro
frat boy kind of punk website and
becomes feminist well when he sees news
hundreds of millions of dollars and then
six months later says we're going woke
everybody it is not the going the other
direction it's flowing one way no no no
i mean it is just flowing always
it's flowing like the the process that's
underway is complementary radicalization
i mean that that is what it is i'm
talking about the right becomes more
right because the left becomes more left
have you seen the pew data on this
well yeah but the pew data you know
unequivocally supports right like the
radicalization online as being a
right-wing phenomenon
that the republican party has moved on a
scale of zero through 10 with zero being
left and 10 being right they've moved
1.5 degrees to the right since 94 and
the left has jumped three points yeah
but it depends it depends also if you
check the check the racial resentment
numbers which spike hugely for
republicans right so like they're
they're they're they're different there
are a whole bunch of ways of reading
those numbers what are those numbers the
racial racial resentment so racial
resentment is like
well it's a pretty complicated
sociological thing it's a bunch of
different factors but it's like how it's
not necessarily racism per se it's
whether you feel threatened
uh and so that and and so that that
number
like rather than being an ideology like
rather than being a ideology as in i am
a racist it is how you feel about
certain aspects of life so that and
those numbers were identical for
democrats and republicans in i think
1990 and then they i again don't quote
me on that but i want to address the
semantic
yes because i would really like
you know we're here we're doing the show
people are listening to it right now
what are we doing to prevent semantic
breakdown
well i don't know i mean having a
conversation that clarifies definitions
like marxism for instance is probably
helpful right racism has come to mean
completely different things
well that's not it's that's essentially
uh well i i don't know that that
you know i've been doing this for so
long that i try to stay extremely
precise
in all the terms like as you said i
don't like to use terrorism unless it is
actually like
the technical definition of terrorism i
like to use like i
part of the book because this stuff is
so fraught i i want to be i want to have
the terminology exact like what is civil
war what is civil strife what is so on
well i think you can be but um it
requires um a certain amount of loss
it requires a certain amount of loss of
force
uh in your argument for sure it does the
the humility the left and the right uh
the right has a traditional view of
language like
we use words that mean things they meant
20 years ago and the left has redefined
things
well the left is involved in a language
etiquette that is totally destructive
and
and just as self-consuming as i said
like there is a there is a well i mean
as mark said in the german ideology like
there was a man who thought if i define
river differently no one will drown
right that's the and that's what that's
what the left has become where they
think that definitions will they think
that definitions will change reality i
have a good example of what i think is
uh contributing to the breakdown and why
i think there's no solution i feel like
many on the right are looking for an
anchor like just tell me where we stand
and what
where we are and i'll try and figure out
what's going on whereas the left just
says i will do as the as the tide flows
so the example on this is but the left
eats itself well certainly they're a
swamp but that doesn't mean that let me
finish this point sorry well nobody goes
away i mean if people went away it would
be easier the point i was going to make
is i saw a meme recently where
someone was talking about vaccines and
then someone responded they they said uh
someone made the meme about seat belts
they were like oh we should ban seat
belt mandates and someone said
you know hate to break it to you but
seat belts aren't intended to prevent an
accident they're prevent to reduce your
risk of injury in the event one happens
and then all of the people on the left
started laughing saying how stupid do
you have to be that's literally what
vaccines do the problem is for people on
the right joe biden came out publicly
and addressed the nation saying vaccines
prevent transmission and dr fauci and
they all said something very similar
now i understand science changes but
it's very difficult to latch onto
something if it goes back and forth so
people well i mean we're dealing like
the the the the situation with like this
is a chaotic moment of of real chaos but
this is like this is that has nothing to
do with semantic chaos that has to do
with the fact of trying to figure things
out also suddenly there's omicron
suddenly i mean the people are people
are doing this on the well you're that's
that's that's that's just you know stuff
happens like you're just trying to
figure out what the hell
i am not saying you know fault on either
side of this what i'm saying one of the
things that that is causing a divide is
people have different tolerances for a
change in information or they have
expectations that's possible although it
seems to me like
the radicalization is happening you know
at the same level
and and happening uh
and
don't you feel everyone's out there
looking for an anchor i mean god knows
the people i talk to on the left are
desperate for some kind of stability i
mean that that's the one hope i have is
that
you know the the the chaos has become so
intolerable to people that they that
they need some kind of they they really
start to crave structures scared to step
through the fire so uh again to throw it
back to jesse smilet for instance
covington kids big cultural moments that
were absolutely wrong for a lot of
people that you know we've even had on
the show they've said this was the
moment i said i just can't live this way
anymore and i need something solid and
so i said i can't trust these people
keep lying to me and i look for
something else
i mean those are very specific moments
like what's the what's the technical
term for the the fallacy where you take
one example and exclude it to everything
else i mean you know everyone has their
example god knows there's a lot of
tolerance because god there's enough
chaos out there there's enough nonsense
but
you know
why like why because they never they
never apologized and never admitted it
see i think
not to be too much of a salesman like
not like i don't like
you actually have a lot of information
about this that i don't have but i think
what i try to do in my book is go thirty
thousand feet in the air i i think your
requires a lot of information i don't
have in people yes i think it does but
to go like i think we need some
perspective on this stuff like jesse
small is not a major incident in
american history
it's a grain of sand in a heap
that's a really good
but it was a joke
but but it wasn't a joke in the sense
the way institutions latched onto it the
way elected officials latched on to it
the media latched onto it and i think
one of the ways where i don't want to
say i disagree with you but where we see
the world differently i do not see the
right trying to cancel the left the way
the left tries to cancel the right small
example of that you have this lovely
singer british chick adele who won an
award and because of the current time
period
a week ago it was a gender-neutral
artist of the year and in her acceptance
of speech she said i wish it weren't i
won't fake a british accent i wish it
weren't uh although she's cockney i wish
it weren't artist of the year i wish it
were
woman of the year because i love being a
woman that turned into adele's trying to
cancel the trans movement adele should
be banned on spotify stop buying adele i
don't ever see that on the right and
proof of that is
two years ago the nfl they kneel at the
anthem stop watching the nfl no one
stopped watching
no one's learning english
look at the super bowl numbers look at
the playoff numbers the right can't go
to a cancel culture the way the left can
what would have to happen for people to
stop watching the nfl it's unimaginable
i don't know exactly like the the civil
war could happen but but the nfl is
gonna continue but look at the movement
to get taylor swift to pull her record
off of spotify because of joe rogan i
don't think you see that on the right
there are calls for it certainly there
are calls for it we should stop the nfl
being the best example we should stop
watching the nfl but they don't but yeah
the right couldn't boycott
these cultural moments boycott netflix
after cuties came out i don't see them
like i can't see the like you guys are
worried you guys are worried about jesse
smollett and you're worried about the
nfl and you're worried about the
halftime show no no no hold on what i'm
worried about hold on those are grains
of sand in the heat yes no no fair
enough i'm worried about
less worried about is that the west's
worried about is that by 2040 50 of the
country is going to be in 50 of the
senate is going to sorry 85 of that
senate is going to be controlled by 50
of the country that's a good thing
but that's well i mean that really to me
devolves into like pseudo democracy or a
constitutional republic not a democracy
uh well see this is where we get into
it's time to separate because like i
think there are two visions of america
one is a constitutional republic a
settler republic and the other is a
multicultural democracy and i think they
are fundamentally irreconcilable i agree
and they and and
they actually they're actually you need
two countries because like the time has
come for
uh like these are both visions that have
their merits and they have their
demerits right but you know certainly i
am on the side of multicultural
democracy
all day forever um that's where i come
you mean like 51
decides the law uh yeah with minority
protections yeah
well those are by law so those are not
the well i mean if you actually want to
know what i believe it's the charter of
rights and freedoms of the canadian
constitution which is incredibly
specific it was written in 1982 and
contains all of this beautifully
articulated in a
simple way but but my point really here
is like
like whichever side you're on of this
these two countries can't coexist like
it has to be one or the other and it
really can't be both i'd like to see
people democratically choosing where
their tax dollars go right but also
having some sort of republicanism that's
that's what i'm talking about
that would be an idea of an amalgam
america has been an amalgam america is a
massive contradiction and you know the
beauty of america its great gift is has
been its capacity to hold contradictory
ideas at the same time
um like that is that is the glory of
america and that's because it's a
constitutional republic it's able to
well i think actually
it's
when you go back to the original
constitution it contains a whole coast
of political ideas that are in conflict
and also you know it believes in it
believes in in struggle as it believes
in disagreement i mean that's that's the
amazing gift of the american
constitution is that it believes that
you don't need
unity you need disagreement to get to
the best answer right but
that that only works if you have a
concept of yourself as a unified whole
and when that evaporates when that
dissolves you're left with
you know
irreconcilability and that like i think
you know have you read washington's
farewell address recently i mean
it's really worth reading because it's a
great work of genius like it is it's a
really fascinating
book because he
worked because he predicts exactly where
you are right now like exactly where you
are right now and he did it
you know on his retirement i imagine you
did a lot of research on the first
american civil war uh yeah i mean
there's so much work on it like i would
never call myself an expert on that like
i definitely read a lot of books about
it but just you know i'm not i would
never there are some things in here that
i do consider myself an expert on but
that there are so many civil war acts
just because um you asked you asked me
earlier what i thought was gonna happen
we didn't quite get into it yeah i will
say we spent a lot of time um you know
you from 30 000 feet me from someone on
the ground trying to explain my
positions i don't think i need to
explain them to you right the most part
i think you know you wrote a book i
obviously want to explain it to the
audience but um as for what i think is
going to happen
we hear a lot of peaceful divorce you
mentioned these two countries can't
exist but there is in my opinion no
scenario in which there is a peaceful
divorce it's almost impossible and uh
the reason for it is actually someone on
the show brought this up i can't
remember who but they made a great point
uh there's two countries you say
multicultural democracy and
constitutional republic both have their
merits
the first civil war what happened it was
like i think four states legally seceded
yeah everybody was like all right then
uh i think seven more states joined in
and they all went well okay then and
then the north said but these military
bases are ours and we're going to remain
in them and that's when fort sumter in
south carolina they said no no no no
hold on you got to leave nobody believed
the muskets were loaded nobody believed
the cannons were armed they all thought
that it was just bluster and there would
be no fighting because it could never
happen here that's right and then the
bombardment started no one foresaw the
first civil war yes like no like even
though in hindsight it all seems
perfectly clear and the structures are
all there and it's like there's no way
that it couldn't be a civil war after
the
nullification crisis and the mum the the
the uh uh
after whatever happened here right like
harper's ferry like we're like 15
kilometers away from where this happened
but like you know after all that but
even fort sumner i mean jefferson davis
said it's probably nothing yep i bet the
the leaders of the north knew there was
something coming
out they're like yo we're getting that
back they had to go to europe to buy
guns yeah the north the industrial super
power of the world in 1850 wow i had to
go to europe i wonder how much of our
treasury they sold out for those weapons
they bought a lot of guns and so here's
what here's what happens now
uh uh
so
that was a great statement um i think
texas had written this that they had
joined the south simply by nature of
geography yes not ideology same thing
would happen today because well they
were texas was a slave state california
for a free state and that's what that's
where they lined up but they were so
nascent i mean you're talking about
you're not talking about large groups of
people right right in the city in the
first year the idea was and then you
also had slave states who joined the
north by by nature yeah geography yeah
because of geography yeah so what what i
think would happen but there was only
one right maryland i think i think it
was with i think west virginia too west
virginia was not a slave state west
virginia right virginia right okay so
what would happen today is you would
likely have new york illinois california
maybe washington maybe oregon
you write all that stuff i imagine i'm
going to show you the map that i got i
want to know i know wait i know i want
to know what you whether you think it's
uh
reasonable but go on please please
so i think it could start with uh rapid
defenderization
but then ultimately what will end up
happening is
one side's gonna say
yeah slide that over
one side's what what's the page number
218. 218. one side's going to say
let me grab this book
hey those those those nukes those
weapons those resources are ours and we
want them the other side's going to say
sorry no dice fighting starts well the
problem is like to negotiate a
settlement you need goodwill right there
are countries that negotiate separation
like czechoslovakia where they do
negotiate in
in in goodwill and that's what happened
with norway and sweden yeah tell me what
you think of that i mean that that is
not a wonder what the best way to show
this is actually because i'm sure i
wonder if is there any so i can't zoom
in
well it's basically the north northeast
and then the south and midwest and then
california to oregon and then texas have
you seen the poll i think it was yougov
data showing the different five
different regions of the us you've got
the midwest south and they were all
basically saying yeah let's break off
you know what you will really like in
that book is the psychometric data which
is like different personality types by
region which is actually fascinating and
like goes to really deep-seated
structural differences between the
between these groups but that the one
that i had only had three i like how uh
texas just goes back to texas well texas
like they have they have a very active
nationalist movement that's quite
together and like and also texas would
100 percent work as a country i i uh
what do you think you think it's close i
think you're close the only issue is i
think it ends up with uh a bunch of war
well the the problem is that first of
all to negotiate a settlement you need
goodwill and then the u.n to negotiate
with the u.n which i know sounds
ridiculous but you know you can't no one
will land in an airport until you have
u.n agreement that you're a separate
country is really really hard especially
with a country that has security uh
general what's it called security
council
uh placement so like it would be
incredibly difficult thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time